voici donc les diables que je dois
gronder
excuse-moi vous croyez que cela va
suffire on se fait pas justice soi-même
c'était un peu plus rassurant qui
m'appartient à moi et moi seul
[Musique]
qui est cet enfant
trois duels ou 3h avec trois
mousquetaires monsieur Atos a le droit
de me tuer en premier monsieur porte son
second et Aramis en dernier je vous prie
de m'excuser par avance si je ne peux
contenter tout le monde
[Musique]
je me trouve bien arrogant jeune homme
c'est ma seule richesse et je la mets
tout entière au service de sa majesté
puis Charles d'Artagnan
que je me souvienne j'ai toujours voulu
être mousquetaire
et peut-être un jour une femme
mousquetaire
[Musique]
s'il te plaît mais j'espère
cette rivalité entre nos troupes et
ridicule
des difficultés
mortes et enterrer
on ne peut pas laisser faire ça mais
innocent
vous voulez donc je déclare la guerre au
protestants et à l'Angleterre
le cardinal fera tout pour faire tomber
la reine
travaillez vous madame le diable
probablement